every year Forbes Magazine releases a
list of America's biggest givers and in
2023 these 25 individuals or pairs made
the list it includes people like Google
co-founder Sergey Brin and Mark
Zuckerberg and his wife Priscilla Chan
these are the piles of money Forbes
reported each of them has given away
collectively a whopping 196 billion
dollars of Lifetime giving at bigger
than the GDP of most countries this
giant pile of money has done a lot of
good but it's hiding a more complicated
and problematic story of billionaire
philanthropy in America we'll show you
how
[Music]
the Forbes list ranks the biggest givers
by how much they've given over a
lifetime biggest to smallest and they
only measure dollars given to charitable
recipients that means it excludes money
parked in a foundation we'll get back to
that and money pledged but not paid out
you'll see here that Warren Buffett and
Bill and Melinda French gates are
standouts
this chart we're making measures the
giver's current net worth adding their
philanthropic giving to that we came up
with a percentage of their net worth
they've given away
foreign
puts Buffett's current net worth at 106
billion and he's given away 51.5 billion
dollars in his life which puts him at 33
percent Bill and Melinda French Gates
who are divorced but still do
philanthropic work together have a
collective net worth of 109 billion
dollars and have given 38.4 billion away
most of this group's donations go to
poverty and public health around the
world and education in the U.S and
together Buffett and the Gates has
created the giving pledge a promise by
the world's wealthiest individuals and
families to dedicate a majority of their
wealth to charitable causes
that's over 50 percent they're almost
there but not quite these 13 givers have
signed it too
including Facebook co-founder Dustin
Moskowitz and his wife Carrie tuna Jeff
bezos's ex-wife Mackenzie Scott and
Michael Bloomberg the other signatories
fall around here
only two of them have made it over the
50 percent line the banker T Denny
Sanford has given 53 percent of his net
worth away and duty-free Shoppers
founder Chuck Feeney almost every last
penny of his fortune
George Soros hasn't signed the giving
pledge but he belongs here too he's
given 73 percent of his wealth away the
eBay founder and his wife go here and
everyone else on the Forbes list Falls
roughly in this area over the course of
their lives they've given 12 or less of
their net worth away
in the least flattering zone of the
chart the highest net worth but the
lowest proportion of it given away is
Jeff Bezos the founder of Amazon is the
richest person on this chart his 117
billion dollar net worth dwarfs his 2.7
billion dollars of philanthropic giving
it's only 2.3 percent of his wealth over
his lifetime
for context that's about as much as what
Americans on average consistently give
as a proportion of their disposable
income per year about 2 percent
bezos's money has gone to various causes
like fighting climate change education
he even gave a hundred million dollars
directly to Dolly Parton lasers is
philanthropic reputation at this point
it's kind of that he doesn't have one
it's kind of hazy is what a lot of
experts have told me that's wizzy Kim a
senior reporter for Vox who covers
billionaires a lot of people speculate
that that's one of the reasons he's made
this recent announcement of I'm
eventually going to give my net worth
away there was a lot of pushback a lot
of speculation around hey Jeff why
aren't you more involved in philanthropy
this chart helps us see who the real
standout givers are those who give most
of their wealth away and those who hold
on to their enormous fortunes
even if a certain individual is very
generous if overall this class of people
just keeps amassing more and more money
we've got to look at ourselves and ask
okay what are we doing wrong here and
how do we reverse this
all this money creates with the
institute for policy studies has called
top heavy philanthropy where individual
wealthy donors make up a large portion
of charitable giving since 2011 Mega
Gifts of one million or more from single
donors have been growing
if you are a relatively small
institution that receives funding from a
very large philanthropist they take
their money away you are in trouble this
chart breaks down charitable tax
deductions by household income levels
since the early 90s nonprofits used to
rely on the broad support of the
population in 1993 77 percent of
charitable deductions were taken by
households making less than two hundred
thousand dollars today that chart has
almost flipped households making more
than one million dollars were taking the
most charitable deductions
so just a handful of people are deciding
what merits philanthropic money and how
these causes should be solved ultra
wealthy donors tend to give to different
causes than the rest of us an analysis
of the chronicle of philanthropy's top
50 donors shows that they give to
education more than the causes
non-wealthy donors give to like to
health a lot to religion the environment
and international affairs
that could mean a billionaire giving 500
million dollars to his alma mater for a
new building on campus or another giving
750 million dollars in one single
donation to charter schools in 20 U.S
cities
a relatively small amount of money can
have a great impact on a specific School
District or a single Charter School the
top 50 donors are also more likely to
give through a private Foundation
most of the people in the Forbes list
have had their own private foundations
or they give to them
here's how they work donors make large
charitable gifts to a foundation in the
form of cash assets or stocks in return
they get huge tax benefits immediately
but the foundation only has to give
money to actual Charities at a rate of
five percent a year
that means money can stockpile in here
donors reap the tax benefits while
Charities may only get a trickle over
time
the Forbes list only counts this money
that foundations have already given to
charity not the money parked here
meanwhile this money continues to enrich
donors there's another way billionaires
donate that the Forbes list doesn't
count at all Donor advised funds which
are more secretive by Design
these are charitable savings accounts
that allow the donor to be anonymous and
offer even bigger upfront tax benefits
more importantly they have no reporting
or payout requirements so it's difficult
to tell whether the money is going
somewhere good or just lowering the
donor's tax bill
donor advice funds have been rising in
popularity meaning collectively they are
housing billions of dollars yet to be
paid out to charities
as of 2020 that figure was 160 billion
dollars
and the huge multi-billion dollar
endowments of Foundations means they
have a lot of power like the Gates
Foundation in terms of global Public
Health The Gates Foundation does get a
lot of credit for their work in
improving vaccine access for preventable
diseases for very young children since
they've been doing their work in this
child mortality rates like infant
mortality under five has gone down a lot
their Foundation is also the largest
private donor to the World Health
Organization which tells you a lot about
just how much agenda setting power they
have and what kinds of public health
problems to prioritize the biggest
criticism is that it's undemocratic
former Enron executive John Arnold and
his wife Laura have been advocating for
reform of Donor advised funds by
lobbying Congress to require them to
distribute funds within 15 years or for
donors to only get a tax deduction upon
distribution to charities
others Advocate to increase the payout
requirements of Foundations from 5
annually to 10 percent these types of
reforms are small fixes to the system
but if our country didn't have such
dramatic wealth inequality we wouldn't
have to rely on the charitable whims of
these billionaires to begin with